the writers seem to delight in putting  your character GD in somewhat  humiliating positions they it seems to  be something that they enjoy doing what  have they done I'm thinking of one  example in particular where they were  they shot a scene I think in a  supermarket and you had a lot of anxiety  about it would you tell us about that  please yeah I have my titties out  he knows he's out yeah and you know but  I mean this that's not the only thing  they've done to me they've they've shot  me in the face with the blood cannon  I had acupuncture I got 50 needles in  the face like Hellraiser for real they  actually sent me to an acupuncturist and  he stabbed me 50 times in the face and  and he was actually laughing as he was  doing it I've never heard of an activist  who laughs as they do that I know that  seems to be contrary to the whole  philosophy ya know that's the kind of  acupuncturists you would be just  laughing as I put it I guess they don't  go in the eye after all